un embouteillage dans une grande ville
une attente interminable
la vapeur est en train de monter les
cadrages au volant sont plus documentée
dans les grandes villes effectivement
que dans les campagnes parce que y'a
plus de facteurs de frustration donc
plus de risque d'embouteillage plus de
risque d'avoir de la construction plus
de risques de retard donc plus de
stresseurs en général finalement dans le
cas de michael douglas la rage explosera
parce que lors des déjeuners est
terminée amélie sort dans la vraie vie
c'est cet homme qui va fracasser la
vitre arrière d'une voiture où ces
femmes qui vont en venir aux mains avec
un vocabulaire un peu fleuri selon la
psychologue
l'agressivité est nécessaire à la survie
de l'humain si on arrive à la réguler
les gens qui manifestent par exemple de
la rage au volant sont vraisemblablement
des gens qui sont plus impulsifs dans
leur vie qu'ils ont qui sont moins
tolérants la frustration qui sont
peut-être moins susceptibles d capable
justement d'autocontrôle que la conduite
charge c'est qu'on est dans un habitacle
une certaine distance entre l'autre et
nous et
certains pouvoirs du fait qu on est au
volant d'un véhicule qui va plus vite
que nous il ya ce conducteur britannique
qui ne supporte pas de se faire rappeler
à l'ordre
après être passé trop près d'un cycliste
ou ce coup avec leurs enfants sur une
route du texas agressé par un autre
conducteur pour un parent d'avoir ses
enfants mais avant ces jeunes enfants le
stress est encore plus rare parce que là
évidemment laisser l'eau justement notre
propre agressivité vont nous a aidé nos
propres réflexes de survie vont nous
aider parce que on va on va vouloir
protéger
évidemment les nôtres et probablement
évité de mettre de l'huile sur le feu
comme cet homme en belgique qui va
sortir un objet de son coffre une mise
en scène qui montre qu'il est possible
de canaliser son agressivité autrement
si on est capable d'instaurer une zone
tampon est désormais entre entre le
moment où l'événement survient et le
moment où j'agis je vais prendre le
temps prendre sa respiration
ça peut déjà calmer un peu le jeu est
parfois le karma se charge aussi
d'infliger une leçon à l'engager comme
notre conducteur britannique qui voulait
frapper le cycliste ici mathieu prost
radio canada montréal